hello everyone I just like to take a
moment to thank ameno for sponsoring
this video
Amino is a global community that you can
join to share your passion with
like-minded people all over the planet
some fondles I love include SCP
obviously Resident Evil and Metal Gear
Solid but I can say with confidence that
pretty much any fandom or interest you
have there will be an imino community
surrounding it take my personal favorite
the SCP Amino community this gives me a
pretty convenient way to create polls to
find out what kind of video I will
create next engage with other fans about
theories on certain favorite SCP entries
and check out some pretty cool fan art
so what can the SCP MVNO community do
there's a featured feed for the most
popular stuff going on that day Oh check
it out zero three five and zero four
nine Pinton nice I think that's pretty
awesome in the bottom left hand corner
is the live layer so as you can see if
29 members chatting four people voting
on polls you get the idea
there's a ton of text and voice chats
that said pretty much any occasion I
think I would be remiss if I didn't join
this hello I'll get back the bat chat
later as I said before I'm also an
artist so I'll be posting some of my SCP
artwork to give them a look check the
comments section or the video
description of this video
join the SCP Amino community and get
started now on with the video enjoy
dear Miss Jacobs it is with deepest
regret that I write to you today
your son Mickey has been killed in
action in the course of his duties under
my command the loss of a child is
difficult for any parent yet you should
know that agent Mickey Jacobs was one of
the finest men I ever commanded Mick was
dutiful and kind with an easy smile a
smile he professed on several occasions
he got from you the impact that his loss
had on us can only be a fraction of that
which you must now be experiencing his
devotion to the principles of Honor and
self-sacrifice lived in every part of
his life and it was self-sacrifice of
the highest order that led to his death
it is left to me then to provide my
fullest devotion to the principle of
Honor and it is that honor that demands
from me a truthful retelling of the
events which led to his passing first in
the interest of frankness your son was
not a security guard for a Lumber
Company your son was a hero on August
18th of this year
your son was stationed at one of our
organization's facilities in South
Alabama a security breach occurred in
one of our high-risk sectors and your
son was sent in as part of a team of
individuals to stop the threat your son
was at the front of a formation of seven
agents when an automated door sealed him
inside the facility without his team
with no support and spotty communication
your son made his way towards danger
providing fire support for the site
security staff on one of the lower
levels he was then tasked by the site
director to rescue several of our
research staff from the monsters that
now roam the site
he was killed during the final rescue of
these staff today a dozen of our best
minds are still alive because of your
son I cannot begin to understand the
sorrow you must now feel but know that
your son's death was not in vain and
that he will be remembered by all those
who knew him as a brave dutiful and
honorable man sincerely and most
remorsefully yours agent Jonathan
Bradley did father ki has detected an
attempt to disseminate classified
materials intercepting redirecting and
replacing within phonesat approved cover
story agent on - Bradley is to be
reprimanded for this attempt
dear Miss Jacobs enclosed is the
remainder of Mickey Jacobs severance pay
as you were listed as mr. Jacobs
emergency contact we trust you to remit
this payment to him in our stead
it should be noted that despite mr.
Jacobs recent problems with drug
addiction and sudden disappearance we
will be willing to provide
rehabilitation services at any time he
should return thank you for your time
chief of security Jonathan Bradley
southern crosscut pipes
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre bashert Andrew were chewy aqui
I apologize if I'm pronouncing that
wrong Andrew please get in touch if I
have Jax Merrick Pierce M Hamlin Austin
Thomas Aldridge Desmond Hoskins Depp's
McGee
dr. mortis Johnno Porter
Cody tench diver ball on sy7 actual if
you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the voting
thank you
you